yeah so I I'm gonna talk about machine
learning today and okay cool so yeah I'm
gonna talk about machine learning and as
a fun case study I've turned on these
little captions that Google slides will
do for you just in case anybody has some
sort of auditory impairment hopefully
you can see those and if not then I'm
serious so my first question for you
today is have you ever applied for a
credit card I know I have a few months
ago I went online and was trying to
trying to get a credit card and it had
this form where I had to enter a bunch
of really personal information and then
at some point I clicked a button that
said submit and the page loaded and
while that page loaded apparently they
were able to make a decision because it
told me whether or not I got this card
immediately and it's kind of blew my
mind because first of all it's crazy
that they were able to make this
decision so quickly and second of all
like I was signing up at 2:00 a.m.
because apparently my idea of a good
time like all my friends are out
clubbing right because I guess that's
what cool people do but I was home like
trying to churn credit card rewards
because that's my idea of a good time
so it's 2:00 a.m. why are think there
can't be humans sitting here grading
these things and even if they're we're
how could they do it so quickly and the
secret here lies in machine learning in
other words they're able to use past
information to determine whether or not
I was a good candidate for this credit
card that's kind of what we're gonna be
talking about today before I get into
all of that I work for a company called
indeed my name is Samuel Taylor in every
single indeed presentation I think
you're legally required to have this
slide that says we help people get jobs
if you are interested in helping people
get jobs please come talk to me
afterward we love data stuff and we love
talking to data people there are many
things that this talk is and that it
aspires to be chief among them is to
introduce people to machine learning so
if you aren't familiar with it you are
in exactly the right place and I'm so
glad that you're here
it aims to be very friendly to people
who are new to this so even if you're
familiar with programming and data and
stuff and if you have no idea what
machine learning is
you will be fine here don't worry about
it at the same time I hope that this is
in some way helpful to people who have
more experience I always find it
enjoyable to see what other people have
worked on and try to understand the
problems that they ran into and so I
hope that in that way if you do have a
little bit more experiences will be
helpful for you the talk focuses on
application because I have found it more
interesting to hear about applications
of machine learning than to hear about
the theory over and over again at the
same time I try to respect the theory
that's button that underlies all these
things because it is really really well
thought through there's been a lot of
research into it and it can make us
better practitioners a lot of things
that this talk isn't the gist is it's
not a it's not a comprehensive tutorial
today like we only have 45 minutes maybe
40 who knows so if there's other things
that you want to talk about I'm happy to
chat with you afterward but we're just
gonna go with a sort of overview today
this is the way we're gonna be doing
that will first talk about just what
even is machine learning and then the
bulk of the talk is gonna be these use
cases where in each one we're gonna
learn something new about machine
learning and about what happens when we
try to do that in the real world let's
start by talking about what machine
learning even is so for those of you
gathered in the audience today if you've
ever heard the phrase machine learning
before can I get you to raise your hand
there's some of you who are lying
because I've already said it today and
I'm gonna keep an eye on you because I
can tell I know that I know which ones
are you are crafty okay for those of you
who are who just raise your hand that's
great if you have used machine learning
definitely like in production but even
if it's just like a cool project that
you did on the weekend or something that
you thought was really interesting could
you also raise a hand okay cool awesome
glad you're here
for those of you who didn't raise your
hand for that I'm so glad you're here
and there's gonna be a lot of learning
so those of you who did raise your hands
hopefully there's some new stuff in here
for you too
when I first waded into this world it
felt like I was trying to ride the
subway in a foreign city and I would ask
for directions and people would say oh
well obviously you just do this and this
and this and it felt like someone was
saying we'll just take the purple line
to the yellow line and they get off at
this stuff I don't know what these
things are or what directions
should be going how could I possibly
know this so to try to make this a
little bit more concrete and not so
scary people will break down machine
learning into a bunch of different areas
and that's what I've drawn up here on
the board today there are a bunch of
different things that we could talk
about this is the way that a lot of
people find useful to break things down
into so there's supervised machine
learning unsupervised machine learning
then there's a whole lot of other stuff
today we're mostly gonna be talking
about supervised learning and this
primarily breaks down into
classification problems and regression
problems in classification problems we
have some input data and some output
data here the input data is yellow so we
have someone's age and their net worth
and then the output data is in purple or
pink I guess depending on if I'm
colorblind and what we see here is we're
trying to predict from this input data
what is the value for the output data
here we could draw this on a graph and
look at it this way is just a convenient
way to look at it and what we're doing
when we're trying to do machine learning
for all of the hype and excitement and
seemingly magical claims that people
make about machine learning the real
thing that happens is we just draw a
line like that's the whole magic is we
just figure out a really good way to
draw lines and that solves a lot of
problems as it turns out so machine
learning is kind of this project to get
really good at drawing lines and
sometimes these lines are a little
squiggly but there's the lines you know
so what we could do is after we draw
this line then ask a question about okay
this new person comes in they are this
old they have this net worth should we
give them a credit card so that's that's
an example that sort of harkens back to
this intro idea of should we give person
a credit card and this is a way we could
teach a computer to do that as an aside
this is obviously just like a fake
example that I drew in particular you
might notice that this very rich 12 and
a half year old who has like $500,000
that's a one percenter right there
anyway so then because this point that
we're asking about is above this line we
can now say yeah we would probably give
this person a credit card regression is
another kind of supervised learning
problem where we still have inputs and
outputs in this case I've drawn the
graph a little bit differently we have
our input along the x-axis and that's
the network
so given somebody's net worth how big of
a credit limit do we want to give them
and maybe we want to give people with a
large net worth more credit because we
think they're more likely to pay it back
and we could look at this data that we
have in the past say you know we did
have a bunch of humans in the room and
they did see you know they did actually
do these reviews of people and did make
a good decision about what size of loan
they were going to give someone and
that's the data that we have drawn up
here and then for all the hype and all
the magic you just draw another line so
that's kind of what machine learning is
and that's great and that's awful and
that's just what it is so then what
happens is after we've learned this
model when a new customer comes in we
can put wherever they are on the input
data in this case on the x-axis we can
say this new customer coming in has a
$500,000 networks we can jog up to the
line we drew and then jog over the
y-axis and say we're going to give this
customer a sixty thousand dollar line of
credit so those are both examples of
supervised learning let's now talk about
unsupervised learning so the main
algorithm I think is interesting or good
to know when we talk about unsupervised
learning is clustering and what's kind
of interesting in unsupervised
applications is we want to know we want
to know something about the data but
we're not sure what so here we might
have these nine data points these nine
different shapes and they have a
different number of sides and they have
different colors and we might tell the
computer hey can you turn these data
points I have into three different
groups and the computer can say yeah
totally here's a group like I grouped
them by color and you're like thank you
computer that's great but there's no
reason the computer couldn't have given
you back these groups instead groups by
shape so clustering is a way that we try
to find some underlying structure in the
data without having an explicit output
whereas in supervised learning we had
either a number or we had a like we had
it we had how much credit did we don't
want to give somebody that's a good
example of a number or we have a sort of
binary yes/no decision and that's Lieut
an example of classification whereas in
clustering we don't have that we just
have data and we want to get some
structure out of it there's a lot of
other stuff
that is machine learning this kind of
looks like it's a you know a PowerPoint
slide in secret it's actually
an insurance policy against people
yelling at me on Twitter so if your
favorite algorithm is not covered it is
it's right here on the slide
to summarize machine learning uses data
to come up with some approximation for a
function that we care about the goal of
machine learning the thing we really
want to do is find this f of X this
function this magical function that
takes input and produces the exact
output so we can take in the past stock
prices and predict the future that'd be
amazing that'd be the coolest thing ever
we can make so much money but the
problem is that we don't know what
happens in those situations we don't
know how this function works the stock
market is very crazy and there's a lot
of factors that go into there's so many
different players in it there are so
many different factors that come into
this that it might even not be possible
to know what moves the stock market the
nice thing is that we can measure points
drawn from this f of X we can look at
past examples from history and say we
see that when this happens then this
next thing is likely to happen so when
someone releases that they miss their
quarterly earnings the stock will
probably go down something like that the
problem is there's some noise in there
but it can give us hope that we do have
some information some signal in there as
well so to summarize the way that I
think about machine learning is it is a
set of algorithms in which we try to
find some function G of X that
approximates f of X reasonably well let
us now begin with our first use case of
the day all of these use cases are going
to go through these five questions the
first question there's going to be what
is the problem in this case the question
is should we the bank give this consumer
a credit card so a consumer comes to us
and we want to know whether we should
give them a credit card the data looks
something like this this is the same
data I showed you before I just figured
out how to use Google slides better and
made a prettier table so we have some
data we have age and net worth and then
we know whether or not this person was
given credit here's my favorite part and
it will soon be your favorite part of
each of these these cases is the
question what kind of machine learning
problem is this so this is the audience
participation part it does this sound
like a classification problem a
regression problem a clustering problem
something else shout at me get your
anger classification does anybody
disagree
anybody think it's something other than
vacation seen some headshake yes y'all
are very astute great work yes this is a
classification problem the solution here
we are at a PI data conference the
solution is Python and scikit-learn it's
gonna be great and it's surprisingly
simple to do something like this we can
import this linear classifier from
scikit-learn and then set up our data I
have it drawn up here in that same graph
that we had earlier just to represent it
this data here is just trying to
represent the stuff we had on the graph
we can instantiate the classifier object
call fit and fit is that step where we
draw the line in the first place so by
calling fit we come up with some line
that separates these two classes and
then when a new person comes in who is
63 years old and has $500,000 we can
figure out whether or not the model says
we should give them credit by calling
this predict method and that's where I
have this question mark that new person
came in and the model output whether or
not we should give them credit and in
this case we should when I do this my
first question is is this good like
should I use this model how accurate is
it like can I use this and this is where
we get into some tricky things with
machine learning about measuring error
this is not a trick question who thinks
that model a this this blue line that I
have that sloping down into the right
who thinks that model a is doing a
better job at approximating these points
than model B is does anybody think okay
good I warned you it was a trick
question yeah model B is definitely
better if we look at this true function
this this actual f of X which is his
green line that I drew we can see that
the blue line on the right is a lot
closer to that line than model a is and
that's easy for us to see as human
beings we can see oh these lines are
pretty close to each other that's good
but we have two things confounding us
here first of all in real life we don't
know where the Green Line is we don't
know the true function that underlies
all of this the second thing that's
tricky is that we have to come up with
some way of quantifying the amount of
error here we can look at these lines
and say they're close but how do we tell
a computer to figure out how close two
lines are the basic thing that we should
do here is two random
we split our data up into training data
and testing data and there is the the
gist here is that if we had a bunch of
data we could randomly say 20% of it
let's not look at it let's train the
model on the other 80% and then we can
evaluate it on the testing data so
there's a again a great scikit-learn ma
method called train test split that you
can use to do this and then we can train
a model so what I did here let me
explain me is this graph a little bit
what I did here was took the data that's
on the Left trained a model on it and
then the sort of regions that are
colored in are the predictions from the
model so the model thinks that this blue
region is the area where all the blue
points live and it's wrong in some cases
like it doesn't realize that there's
some there should be some blue points up
here even in the training data it wasn't
able to perfectly get this function
correct and there's a little orange
point over here that it also did not
correctly identify and that will happen
but the interesting thing here is that
because we set the testing data aside
and because we separated it completely
at random we can now take the same
colored regions overlay them on our
graph of the testing data and then count
up how many areas it makes so we see in
this case it makes two errors out of 20
points and so we might think that okay
in the real world when we're doing this
because on our testing data it made 2
out of 20 errors we might think that our
model is going to be wrong in 10% of the
cases and that's a way we can get a
sense for how good our model is ideally
at this point what you would do is
calculate the actual cost of something
bad going wrong and what I mean by that
is if we were trying to build a system
that took in radar data and tried to
determine whether a nuclear warhead was
coming at the US and we're wrong like
there's not actually a nuclear warhead
everyone's gonna die because we're gonna
shoot our nukes and then everyone's
gonna shoot Nixon ever was gonna die and
it's gonna be the destruction of the
human race it's the worst thing that we
can imagine happening right and the same
goes for if a words actually coming to
us and we don't see it like there's no
chance for us to shoot it down a bunch
of people die it's really bad so there's
real world cause costs there but not
every problem is like this think about
me fingerprinting into my phone if
somebody if like I'm trying to get into
my phone and it does it rejects my
fingerprint and
I get a little bit annoyed but I just
tap it again and then it realizes it on
the second chance and so rejecting me
that first time was fine like it's a
little bit annoying but it's a lot
better than somebody who's not me being
able to get into my phone so if that
happens someone's able to fingerprint it
to my phone they can look through my
memes and tell me that they're not funny
and that's gonna hurt my feelings deeply
I'm gonna have to go get some therapy
after that and that's like a really like
yeah those people are expensive is like
$80 an hour so it's there's a lot bigger
cost they're associated so ideally what
we could see is in our testing data we
made this kind of error this often and
that kind of error results in $80 of
therapy time whereas the other error
results in like 50 cents of annoyance
and you could multiply those numbers
together add them all up and see how
good your model is actually doing in the
real world it's not always possible to
do that unfortunately so what we have to
do is come up with different error
metrics that kind of get us close to
that or get a some way of comparing
models to each other for regression
problems the common one is called mean
squared error I have an example here
where we might have some true values
that we know that we split out as part
of our testing data and then some values
that I have drawn in green and with a
little extra outline there in case you
are color blind though I don't know if
you can tell as much up on the screen
but hopefully the ones with a stronger
outline are the ones that are predicted
values and what you can do is subtract
those numbers from each other and then
square those and take the average so
then you can add up to this last column
here divided by four and say the average
mean squared error was eighteen point
three five for this model and that gives
you some sense for how good or bad this
model is that you can use to compare to
other models that you might have another
kind of error that you might or another
another thing that people often use this
classification error which is when you
have some when you have some
classification problem you can just look
at how many areas you're making and so
in this case we see that we make one
error we accidentally classify a point
that is truly orange as blue and that
means that we have roughly a 25%
classification error so these are
metrics that we can use to quantify how
good our models are so at the end of
each use case we'll talk about some
lessons that we learned first thing is
that it's pretty neat it's just math and
computers are able to figure this stuff
out and you don't
actually have to be a linear algebra
genius to use this stuff and to get
value from it another thing that we
learned was very important is to have
testing data so that way we can evaluate
our models let's now move on to our next
use case in which we will teach a
computer sign language so we'll start
again like all the use cases with what
is the problem problem is I don't know
sign language but there's a lot of deaf
people that I would love to communicate
with because they have valuable things
to communicate and I think that's messed
up that I just I can't communicate with
them so I found this little device that
you can plug into your laptop and it has
a little like infrared camera and
infrared LEDs and stuff in there and in
real life you can't see this little like
you can't see this little violet thing
that's coming out of here but that's an
IR LED I don't know about photography I
don't know why you can see it in the
picture but anyway it shines IR on your
hand and as you're moving around your
hand it can sort of track where your
individual joints are something like
this so in this example someone has the
device on their desk and they're holding
up their hands something like this and
the computer is able to turn that into
this three-dimensional data so the data
itself looks like this we have 20
different points on the human hand and
it gives us x y and z coordinates for
all 20 of those and most of those are
joints but there's one in the middle of
the middle of your palm and I think
there's one at the wrists or something
so what what my friend and I did was we
took this device and we were at a
hackathon and we decided let's try to do
something to solve this sign-language
problem so we plugged a thing into our
laptop and we said we looked up the ASL
alphabet and we're like let's just try
the alphabet first so plug it in and
we're like ok I was making a above the
sensor and like move it around and tell
it hey this is an A and just repeatedly
told it an A and then made it B above
the sensor and hit B a bunch of times
and eventually we have this data set
that you see on the screen where we have
some points for each joint we have XY
and Z points and then we have a number
of signs that we can try to predict so
our inputs are going to be these 60
points these 60 data points and then our
output is going to be what sign is the
person making a through Z here's the
best part
what kind of machine learning problem is
this
okay clustering is anybody think is
anything different from clustering some
one thing is classification okay
everything is anything other than
clustering or classification okay so it
is a common actually when I get in this
talk before sometimes people think this
is clustering it's not actually in this
case and the reason is that in
clustering we don't know what we want to
predict but in classification we do so
in this case we do know that we want to
predict an A through Z and and in this
case we so because you have 26 different
things that you're trying to predict
you're trying to predict it's it's a
member of one of these 26 classes it is
a classification problem so yeah it's a
classification problem and but not
uncommon to think this clustering and
clustering you could you could do
clustering on this it just wouldn't be
this exact problem that we were trying
to solve you might learn something else
by doing clustering so when we go into
the solution right here the first thing
that we did was try to choose a model we
had this data and we were trying to
think what model is going to work well
on it so just like we've already learned
it's a good idea to split your data up
into training data and testing data and
then we just like imported every model
we could from psych Atlanta and we said
let's just try a bunch of these things
and evaluate them on the test data let's
just train them and then run through and
see which one does best
this actually is not the worst thing you
could do it's not like the greatest
thing ever also but like it it's as long
as you're not doing this repeatedly over
and over again and you could probably be
okay doing this you can run a risk if
you do this over and over again you end
up picking a model that just does really
well in your training data but your
real-world data might not look like your
training data unfortunate or not might
not look like your testing data
unfortunately but this is not a bad
first approach at this and so then we
thought okay cool we got this amazing
model this is great let's build an
application the first thing we thought
was let's make a keyboard let's make it
to where you can type in you know
letters a B whatever and it will turn
that into some text on a screen that you
could use to type back and forth not
that like people can't type but we just
thought it was an interesting idea
turned out this did not work very well
we were having a difficult time figuring
out like when are people changing the
sign that they're making and so we're
like well let's just scrap that entirely
and come up with something else so we
figured out that our model was still
good enough that we can make a little
educational game kind of like a rosetta
stone for sign language thing
and this is a little let's see if this
YouTube video wants to load there's no
sound on this or anything but the it
shows you a little image of a letter and
says hey make this sign this is an a
this is a B whatever and then as you get
it correct it will give you points and
at the end you get to type your name in
as a little like leaderboard because I
guess everyone loves leaderboards anyway
I'm not very good at this game but the
so this is just a little demo to get
give you an idea of what you can kind of
do with this stuff so there are some
things that we learned in this process
and surprisingly a large amount of
things that I learned from this that are
applicable today in my real-world life
that I didn't think I was going to learn
from just this sort of 24-hour toy
hackathon thing the first thing is that
defining the problem is really important
in really challenging being able to
figure out from this sensor like what
can I even what data can I even gather
from it what is something that I find
interesting kind of coming up with the
intersection of that and then coming up
with okay what if we did sign language
okay well actual sign language has its
own grammar and its own rules and
there's a lot of their signs that move
for instance and so you can't do
something just based on the Sabbath
there's so many so much complexity of
this but being able to come up with some
problem that you can concretely solve
and casting it as a machine learning
problem is very difficult and I think
really important to be able to do the
thing that I'm able to do get make any
progress was to limit scope again I
thought this was something we were just
doing because we had a 24-hour hackathon
in real life this ends up being super
important to when you have a problem
that is large oftentimes the best way to
solve it is to break it up into smaller
problems and then solve those
individually so in this case we said
sign language is is cool and then we're
here maybe just American Sign Language
maybe just the alphabet which isn't
super useful but gets you a start at
understanding what the kinds of problems
that you run into are we talked a little
bit about model selection here and this
for one exposed me to the problem of
model selection and how to figure out
what model to use and got me familiar
with at least one method of doing that
the another really important sort of
lesson that I learned was that it's more
than just the model you have you might
have a model that will make you a
garbage keyboard that doesn't work very
well at all but the model could still
have value in being used for this
rosetta stone esque application which is
interesting if you're if you're working
in a corporate context this is a great
place to sit with the product people and
sit with your customers and try to
understand what are their pain points
and what are things that I can solve
with machine learning to make their
workload lighter or more efficient or
whatever move now to forecasting energy
load so the problem here is that we have
to know when to schedule energy
production imagine that we are an
electricity grid and we need to know
when to want to make our power plants
start generating electricity because I'm
not an engineer like batteries aren't
good I guess and so you have to schedule
your energy production close to one it's
going to be used I think this isn't
entirely this is not entirely
hypothetical so for any of you who are
here from out of town there's this thing
in Texas called arc hot which is the
energy reliability Council of Texas and
everywhere except well most places
except notably Austin have this
deregulated energy market where people
can buy energy from whoever they want
and I think what ends up happening is
those providers turn back around and buy
it from ERCOT or something I don't know
again there's a lot of things I don't
know but this is a problem that you that
someone has and they have to figure out
how to solve it you can see that they
divide up the state into these different
weather zones because as it turns out
energy usage course correlates highly
with Corley's highly with weather so the
data kind of looks like this we have
some time some time of the day in the
hour the date in the hour and then the
output we have actually like nine
different outputs here and you can
download these Express Excel
spreadsheets from Orkut themselves and
they'll say hey this is how much power
was used across the state or in each of
these weather zones during this hour so
the input here we have is the time of
day and the output is the energy load
being used in terms of kilowatt hours I
thought it was fun to put this on a
little graph so I did that and even at
this point I think it's kind of
interesting to look and see well in you
know in the summer things get a lot
heavier usage because
gets hot here and people don't like that
so even here I think it's interesting
but we could apply machine learning to
this right so what if we wanted to
predict how much energy usage was
happening and what kind of machine
learning problem is this okay regression
does anyone think is anything other than
regression some of the things clustering
anybody think anything other than
clustering okay it is regression in this
case it's a good good call so and the
reason that it is regression and not
clustering again is because with
clustering we don't know the output
we're not we're not sure what we're
trying to output in regression we know
that we're trying to predict the number
of the the amount of energy being used
so there's a strict number that we're
trying to predict and the reason that
it's not clustering is because
clustering would be predicting like a
distinct number of things whereas with
regression we're trying to pick a
continuous value so there's a number of
things we need to know here yeah with
regression the first is that when we're
dealing with time series data it often
exhibits seasonality this is a graph of
weekly energy load in a cross across the
state of Texas and you can see that
there's big bumps in the summer and then
sometimes I get these little bumps in
the winter if it's a particularly cold
winter people are gonna run their
heaters but that doesn't happen super
often here and what's tricky is this
thing that I told you was a good idea at
the start of the talk which is to
randomly split your data up into
training data and testing data is not a
good idea when you have time series data
and the reason that is is because if you
were to do that and have the AR blue
data be the training data and our orange
data be the testing data we're gonna
leak some information so if we look at
this particular part of the graph
there's an orange point in there that is
a testing data point and it is
surrounded on both sides by blue points
which means that those are points we
know about which means that if we are
trying to test our model and say hey
what would the energy usage be right
here the model can look ahead to the
future and be like well the day after
that it's this so I'm gonna say it's a
little bit less than that and in real
life you don't know that you don't know
the future when you're making these
predictions so what you what you should
do when you have time series data is do
a split that's based on time because
that more accurately reflects the way
that this model will end up getting
used in the way that you will have
information in production so this is an
example of sort of six different slips
that you could make starting with it
starting with you know a little chunk
and then adding on some extra basically
taking a little extra in the future and
saying let's make our model predict for
this you can do this a bunch of times
and get a bunch of different splits
between training data and testing data
and test your model in each of those
cases now another tricky thing about
time series data is that some models are
not very good at it so this is a model I
trained and it just like completely
doesn't miss it doesn't realize that it
can do tricky things like this and that
is not great so it's a good idea to do
something a little bit more more intense
and there's a lot of people who do a lot
of research on how to model time series
problems and I would highly recommend
using this library called profit because
it will take a bunch of that research
into account and make models that are a
lot smarter than than some others so the
main thing that we learned here is that
time series data is really special and
you should think about it very carefully
because it has seasonality don't use a
random split of your training data in
your testing data the last thing we will
talk about today is using machine
learning to find our next job so the
problem here is passive job hunting and
this is a couple years ago at this point
I was reasonably happy in my job but I
was kind of like you know maybe
something coolers out there and I
thought well this would be a fun little
side project to do of gathering up a
bunch of jobs and then figuring out
which ones sound cool and maybe I could
like make a robot email me the coolest
jobs that sounds interesting
and so I made this thing this little
spreadsheet where I would go and enter
in a bunch of jobs and I'd put a link to
the job description and then when I was
bored like I was in line at the you know
are like waiting for the bus or like
waiting first you know I've had like
Subway sandwiches or something I pull up
the thing I click on the Job Description
I would go read it I'll come back to the
spreadsheet and I would say whether or
not that job sounded cool now I will
admit to you just just right now no
judgment hopefully that I spent way
longer doing this than I would have
spent like actually just using a normal
like job search procedure but given that
all of you are at a software conference
on a Saturday I think this is a safe
place for me to admit my
over-engineering tendencies so here we
are at a product question of what kind
of machine learning problem is this we
have some information about a job and
we're trying to predict whether or not
it would sound cool to me I'm hearing
classification does anybody think
anything other ok yes this is a
classification problem
the tricky thing here is we've seen how
we've seen data before where we're
dealing with numbers and we're trying to
say from this number and this number
let's break this value but we have a a
job title now and a job title isn't a
number so it's like what do we even do
here right like how do we turn a job
title into the number 5 like what does
that even mean how would we do that so I
did what I highly recommend you do when
you run into problems is Google just
like how do I do this thing and so I
googled like text representations
machine learning and this is the first
thing it came up it is not a new idea
and but it's a good place to start so
what you do is you take your all of your
documents all of your job titles and put
them on the rows of a matrix and then
make columns for every unique word in
the data set so for instance for this
first one we see that the word engineer
does not occur in the job title so we
say zero but the word web does so we
have we put a 1 in that column and etc
etc I'm not going to go through that the
the tedium of filling this out for you
because that sounds boring one thing I
do want to make sure you note is that in
this model of text if you have a
repeated word you can have multiple
things so if someone posted a job called
data data data data first of all like
I'm interested in hearing about it
second of all you would get a four in
the the data column there and what we
call this is either word count vectors
or a vector space model of language so
now we're able to take a job title and
turn it into this word count vector and
we can take our sounds cool in Dakota as
a one if it sounds cool or zero if it
doesn't so now we have numbers and we
can plug it in to scikit-learn again and
the code look is actually relatively
simple to do this you can take these job
titles take whether or not it sounded
cool do this count vectorizer thing
which does the work of turning these
titles into word count vectors and then
finally train a model on it so we call
fit and that's gonna do our work our
drawing this fancy line and then we can
call predict on the new jobs that we
have coming in and say do these sound
cool or not and they will end up
outputting this array that says these
ones didn't sound cool but that fourth
job did sound cool so I did this and I
got a classification error of 20% about
and I'm thinking this is great like I'm
barely even trying and I'm already
getting 80% accurate this is awesome and
then I dug in a little bit further and I
found out that the base rate was 0.197
which means that only 20% of the jobs I
ever found were cool and my model figure
out I'm just gonna say nothing is cool
and then I'm gonna get 80% right this is
great I'll get a B just for not doing
anything so I drew this self-portrait
after I did that the the thing you
should probably be doing is not just
relying on classification error because
it can trick you in interesting ways one
way that people use to combat this is to
use something called a confusion matrix
where you have the predicted values
along one axis of a matrix and then
along the other the actual values if I
had done this I would very easily be
able to see oh I'm just predicting zero
for everything and all my errors are
coming when there's actually these
interesting jobs and I would know well
that's the only thing I care about so
clearly my model isn't doing well enough
another set of error metrics you can use
when you have this sort of imbalance
situation is to use precision and recall
to put it succinctly precision is a way
of asking for all of the job titles that
I say are cool that my model says are
cool how many of them actually turn out
to be cool and then recall is a way of
saying of all of the job titles that I
know about that are actually cool how
many of them is my model saying are cool
so if I had done this if I had looked at
this I would see that my recall was zero
because I was not predicting that any
title sided cool so zero of the actually
cool and titles were coming back this
cool another useful technique for
imbalanced data is to do resampling of
the data so one thing you can do is take
your that does 80% of jobs that didn't
sound cool and just throw away a bunch
of them because you don't need them and
you can get it closer to a balanced
scenario and your model can
your model won't be incentivized to
cheat as much that way if you make it
balanced and it will realize like well I
have to actually try now is the idea so
I ended up doing under sampling and then
I made this little thing that would
email me once a week I've since turned
this off but it was a fun project and it
would email me once a week and say hey
B's job sounded cool this week I'm go
ahead and look at all right there's some
things we learned the first thing we
learned is understand what the base rate
of your problem is try to figure out if
your model is being silly
if it's trying to be tricky with you you
want to know that you want to know what
would happen if I did the dumbest thing
imaginable I'm just predicted the most
common class in each case another thing
we learned is that a simple model isn't
necessarily ineffective I started this
wanting to like use some crazy like deep
learning stuff on text and then I did
logistic regression which is a very
simple model and realized this works
really well how great but I was also a
little bit sad on the inside and the
reason this works is because of a thing
called the approximation generalization
trade-off what that means is you can
choose between being able to do really
well at the training set or being able
to generalize better to data that you
haven't seen yet to give an example
that's more concrete imagine we have
these data points on the board that are
our training data and I have John the
the truth is this blue line and then I
have built two models a linear
regression model and a nearest-neighbor
model the nearest neighbor model is
incredible at approximating data it
actually has no errors from the train
data it is perfect at approximating the
linear regression model is not as good
as approximating there are places where
it's kind of far from some of the
training data but what's neat is when we
look at the testing data the linear
regression model despite its lack of
approximation does a lot better on
generalization so when we choose simple
models we often are able to generalize
better and that's one reason why we
should choose to use simple models at
first especially is because you get a
lot of generalization ability just by
using a simple model the other thing is
it's just easier like it's been a while
since I've tried to set up tensorflow
where Pytor whatever on my laptop but it
is significantly harder than just pip
install SK learn so it's often easier to
do this and faster to train and you can
iterate a lot more quickly doing use
when you use simple models
okay I'll take a deep breath we've
talked about a lot of things some last
takeaways to sort of try to tie a bow on
this package supervised learning is a
set of techniques where we try to use
past examples to predict either a
continuous variable in the case of
regression or a discrete variable in the
case of classification you can measure
performance of these models by splitting
your data into training data and testing
data before you do the training the
another thing we learned is to keep it
simple because when we try the simplest
thing that could possibly work sometimes
it works and you don't have to try the
hard thing which is very nice when that
happens the last thing I would say is to
test out your models and iterate and you
are going to learn a lot more by trying
out something that you can do very
quickly like a little gistic regression
model and then figuring out what you
need to do next
rather than going through all the work
of building some really complicated data
pipeline is a really complicated model
first because using that simple model
will then enable you to do have much
quicker feedback loops which is really
nice all right that's the best stuff I
have for you today again I work it
indeed and they are really nice for
letting me come do this kind of thing if
you're interested in any of that please
come talk to me the slides are available
at this link here go to indeed comm
slash PDA 19 that's short for PI data
Austin 19 I think we need to get moving
to the next talk so we don't have time
for questions but if you do have
questions feel free to email me I would
love to chat with you the data stuff is
one of my favorite kinds of stuff so
yeah just email me would love to hear
from you and thank you for your time
[Applause]
awesome let's do that yeah I don't know
much about energy consume consumption
but I would assume that it's not only
times his problem but also whether
contribute significantly on how much
energy expense yes I was wondering what
was the reason for you yeah that's so
that's that's a great question um so the
question yeah so he had a mic I won't
repeat it the the main reason for this
is actually just for like pedagogical
reasons it's easier to just talk through
like it's time and the second thing is
that you can actually get a decent model
by using time because time and weather
are so correlated now you can definitely
have it be better by adding in weather
data because there's going to be places
where it's 80 degrees in December like
that just happens sometimes so yeah
that's the main reason this is but yeah
in real life you would definitely want
to use weather in this case
I was just wondering if you had an
example yeah so one thing that I think
is yeah yeah cuz I keep tricking you on
like you think this is clustering no
it's not it's never trust rating so one
thing that I have seen be interesting in
clustering is if you think about like
let's use that that jobs dataset example
if we had some data set of jobs and
let's say we end up having like 9,000
unique words in that it might be
computationally intractable to have a
model that has 9,000 features and so one
thing that some people will do is
cluster those job titles and try to find
groups of job tables that are similar to
each other and then maybe you end up
with like 9 groups and then you can have
you know you could have like 9 features
instead of 9,000 so some people I have
seen people use it as sort of like a way
of understanding the underlying
structure of the data and then using
that to kind of build a model off of
that instead of building it off of the
raw data for some reason yeah another
place I've seen it be used is if you're
trying to understand your customer base
for instance and you want to know who's
buying our product you can gather a
bunch of data about them and then build
some clustering over them and and then
analyze them and figure out like oh
these are small businesses these are
large businesses trying to hire nurses
things like that yeah and that can help
you do a lot of things yeah thank you
appreciate it all
[Applause]